Bell's inequality it's a slightly
obscure piece of quantum mechanics but
it turns out it really is very important
to our understanding of the way the
universe works
so the original paper was written in
1964 by John Bell called on the Einstein
Podolski roses and Paradox the important
issue here is that John Bell essentially
took on Einstein and got the better of
him all right
a little bit of background about John
Bell he was from Northern Ireland died
in the early 1990s I think but he was
quite young he was only in his early 60s
at the time but did quite a lot of kind
of fundamental work on quantum mechanics
but this is the thing that he's sort of
most famous for so here's his paper it's
a bit intense I think it's the way to
describe it in that there's lots of
integral signs and things in there and
it's one of those bits of physics where
I kind of struggled to understand it but
I came across this wonderful other paper
by a guy called David merman called
bringing home the atomic World Quantum
mysteries for anybody which actually
puts Bell inequality and Bell's theorem
which kind of underlies Belle's work
into a much more understandable
framework and gives us an example that
we can look at without horrible amounts
of maths David merman another famous
physicist famous to most undergraduate
physicist because he wrote a book with a
guy called Ashcroft book called Ashcroft
and Merman that lots of people learned
their solid state physics from so he's
kind of a bit of a hate figure amongst
undergraduates but he's a brilliant guy
and comes up with these very clever ways
of explaining things okay
so that's what we're gonna we use
moments experiment we're gonna have to
back up a little bit further
and talk about quantum mechanics and how
you measure things in quantum mechanics
right and so there was a famous
experiment from the 1920s by Stern and
Gerlach in which they did an experiment
to look at the properties of particles
when you pass them through magnets so
this is their apparatus where
essentially you have a bunch of
particles and you pass them between
these pair of magnets and this is kind
of an end on view of what those magnets
look like so it's a very non-uniform
magnetic field that you pass them
through they were interested in the
angular momentum of these particles as
they pass through and the reason why a
magnet allows you to do that is if
you've got a particle that's got say a
spin associated with this but I think
it's rotating then if it's a Charged
particle you've basically got a little
current because you've got charge which
is moving and whenever you have a little
current Loop you create a little magnet
essentially and so you can think of
these particles as if they were little
magnets and when you put one magnet in a
non-uniform magnetic field the net
effect is it exerts a force on it and
depending on which way up that magnet is
it'll make it move in different
directions so they did this experiment
on these particles passing through and
what they found is when you pass them
through this what's now called a Stern
girl like apparatus the particles split
up and it's just to do with what
direction the spin is pointing in and
you can think of them as just little
magnets and it just depends what way up
the magnet is what direction they get
moved in
sorting them it does sort them sorts
them in a very discrete way and that's
where the quantum mechanics thing comes
in because you kind of think well if you
if you've got this thing which is going
to assault things you know if they're
North Poles upwards it'll move them that
way and there's no Falls downward it'll
move them that way you'd think that if
there's something that's kind of in
between it'll move them not kind of not
quite so far
that's not what happens in quantum
mechanics essentially it's either up or
it's down it's never kind of anywhere in
between if you measure it as being up or
down it'll only be up or down and so
what they found was this unexpected
result at the time from quantum
mechanics so instead of finding things
kind of spread around all over the place
that they split into these two discrete
groups of being either up or down and
that's kind of this fundamental thing
about quantum mechanical measurement you
tend to get discrete results rather than
anything in between and this is a kind
of an early example of that what are the
particles going through that magnet then
so in the original Stone girl like
experiment they actually use silver
atoms but there are lots of things so
it's the property that they're picking
up is the spin of a particle and so
actually you could do it with electrons
for example electrons have a spin the
reason why it doesn't work very well in
the sort of classical Stone girl like
experiment is because the charge of the
electron then interacts with the magnets
as well which just complicates the
measurement but basically there's a
whole load of things that will have this
so you can do it with hydrogen atoms for
example as I say the original experiment
was with silver but for most of what the
rest of what we can talk about we'll
just think about just electrons because
it just makes life simpler to think
about them because they're kind of
isolated particles and we don't have to
think about whole atoms or anything like
that okay so we're going to use this
kind of apparatus quite a lot and in
order to avoid having to draw it out
every time for the rest of what I'm
going to talk about we'll just draw it
as an arrow up or down with a question
mark next to it so that's the first bit
we need to introduce then we need to
introduce another bit of quantum
mechanics
which is a thing called an entangled
state
okay and so for example again let's just
think about electrons because it's
easier to think about electrons you can
create electrons in this thing called an
entangled State remember the spins
either up or it's down and you can
create kind of a pair of electrons which
are coupled to each other so if one of
them's up the other one's down or if
that one's down that one's up and
usually you kind of create them close
together but then you can move them
apart but they'll still be in this
entangled state so if we go to an
experiment we're creating this entangled
State we then move the electrons apart
from each other and then we pass them
through one of these sets of apparatus
that measures is the spin up or down it
will always come out as either up or
down never anything in between so you
make the measurement one of them comes
out up the other one comes out there or
you make the measurement one of them
comes out down the other comes out up
and that's the only possibilities that's
always what happens with these things so
one of the things you could do is
instead of measuring up or down you
could just basically take your
experimental apparatus and turn it on
its side and then instead of asking the
question is it up or down you're asking
is the spin left or right so you've got
well your entangled pair will leave one
of our Stone girl like experiments the
same but we'll turn one of them on its
side and suppose for example we measure
this particle and it's up and then the
question is is it left or right well
what it really wants it to be is down
right because it's measured this one is
up and this one's down but we're not
asking that question we're not asking up
or down we're asking left or right and
the answer is it doesn't care so if you
do this experiment you'll find if this
one turns out to be up it'll be kind of
50 50 whether it's left or right and
similarly if this one was down it's kind
of 50 50 whether it's left or right all
right we've taken our operators we've
turned it sideways now let's turn it
upside down
just to take it to kind of its natural
conclusion
so now again we're asking we are
actually making the same measurement
that we were before but it's just one of
our sets of operators is now upside down
so sure enough if this one's up this
one's going to be down but because we
turned the apparatus the other way up
it's kind of up upside down
okay so in terms of the colors I put on
these things right when this one's red
this one's red too just because it's
kind of measuring the opposite thing but
with the apparatus upside down or it
could be that it'll this one will be
down in which case this one will be up
again all of these things are possible
but it all they always come in these
pairs now all right so we've taken the
apparatus we turned it on its side we've
turned it upside down now I want to turn
it back a little bit so it's not quite
upside down anymore here's the story
when we're neither way around
particularly and in particular I'm going
to just turn it to 120 degrees that's a
third of the way around so now if this
one measures an electron up then really
it wants to measure it down here but
again we're not quite asking is it up or
down we're asking something slightly in
between but you can see one of these
arrows kind of points downwards and so
what happens is it's just more likely to
be downwards than upwards and in
particular for this 120 degree angle it
turns out that 75 of the time if this
one's up this one will be pointing
downwards so it'll be the red arrow
again 25 of the time if this one's red
this one will be green okay and so it's
kind of somewhere in between and if you
want the mass for it fairly
straightforward quantum mechanical cap
regulation it turns out that if that
angle there is Theta then the
probability of this 25 is the cosine of
theta divided by 2 squared it's always
that formula okay so just to recap if
this one's up then
25 of the time this one will be up in
other words because we turn the
operators around it'll be the other
color and 75 of the time it'll be kind
of downwards so it's the the same color
because we turn the operators around one
final one of these I promise at the
moment all we've done is turned around
this apparatus but of course we could
play around with this apparatus as well
and so the last thing I want to show you
is if this guy's around 120 degrees if
we rotate this one through 120 degrees
essentially we're just doing the same
experiment we were doing before because
we're just measuring the apparatuses are
now measuring the same direction so it's
kind of exactly the same as the first
example but just with your head turned
on one side and so if this one's
pointing you know down to the right this
one will always be pointing up to the
left and vice versa
that was a quick counter through Quantum
entanglements and the ways that you can
kind of measure spin from of the
particles that are coming out from it so
now we get to David merman's brilliant
experiment and in particular he is so
here is David merman's machine that he
came up with this is kind of a thought
experiment but it's you know it's
actually an experiment you really could
do in practice which is this is the
machine that he came up with it's a box
it has a switch with three positions on
the side and it has two lights on the
back red and green and if you move the
switch to different positions all you do
is you take one of these stone gerlock
apparatuses and you turn it through 120
degrees or 240 degrees okay so it's like
a third of the way around or two thirds
of the way around and then if you make a
Quantum measurement of the spin of a
particle remember it'll always come out
either red or green and if it comes out
red the red light goes on and if it
comes out green the green light goes off
so that's the apparatus that you came up
with and the experiment that he wanted
to do with his apparatus is he wanted
two of these
set up such that create two particles in
a Quantum entangled State send one of
them towards this detector the other one
towards this detector and then all that
happens is depending on where the switch
is you've just got your Stern girl like
apparatus in different orientations and
so you'll get different results and in
particular if the two switches are in
the same position
that means that the two Stone girl like
apparatuses are oriented the same way
either that way or that way or that way
but they're always oriented the same way
which means that if one light's red the
other one's going to be green 100 of the
time because that's what we've just been
showing before if they're in different
settings that means that there are 120
degrees apart from each other in one
orientation or another and whatever
combination you've got the difference
which is they're always 120 degrees
apart from each other and that means
that the lights are going to be
different 25 of the time they'll be the
same 75
this gets us back to that Einstein
Podolski and Rosen Paradox right because
what happens is somehow
the particles come out in this direction
in this direction and what answer you
get is random right if if let's start
with them with the switches being in the
same position so that means that if
one's red the other one's always going
to be green
okay you can't tell until you make the
measurement
which ones red you know whether it's
going to be red this ending with this
end or vice versa suppose we set up this
operator so that one of these apparatus
is a tiny bit further away so in fact
the particle arrives at this one a tiny
bit before it arrives at this one that
means that if this one is red then this
one's always going to be green in other
words if this particle spin is up this
particle spin is always going to be down
somehow the particle knows what
orientation it has to be on instantly
and you can set things up so that the
reason time for any information to pass
from here to here between one
measurement and the other measurement
and so somehow instantly the information
travels from here to here ah that one
turned the red light on so I have to
turn the green light on not only that
but actually the particle over here
knows which orientation to have not only
on the basis of what orientation the
other particle had but what position the
switches are in because the results
depend on what the positions of the
switches are
and again if you want to you can set
those switches at the last possible
moment just before you make the
measurement you don't have to set them
before the particles set off you can set
it at the last possible moment
so somehow instantaneously the
information travels from here to here
not only what orientation that particle
was in but also what position this
switch was in in order to get the right
probabilities of answers over here
Einstein really didn't like this because
Einstein had a bit of a thing about you
know things not traveling faster than
the speed of light that's kind of the
whole relativity
and so he referred to this as spooky
action at a distance
and in fact the this kind of
experimental apparatus was what Einstein
Podolski and Rosen described in their
paper as a kind of a paradox that this
can't be the whole story because it
can't just be probabilities because as
far as he was concerned there's no way
that information could travel
instantaneously from here to here and
that means that somehow before the
particle set out
they had to have kind of reached some
agreement as to which particle was going
to do what hmm
it seems like to me they
of course I of course I know what my if
I'm up or down because when I last saw
my buddy before he left on his journey I
saw what he was well except except what
he is depends is going to depend on what
the switch setting is over here right
and what the switch setting is over here
so you're kind of right the particles
can kind of come to an agreement before
they set off as to okay if this switch
is in position one and this switch is in
position two then you do that and I'll
do that and so on through all the
possible permutations and combinations
and and that's a thing called a hidden
variable that's the the physics is all
set and somehow it's sort of the
electrons carry that information with
them so that when they arrive at the
detectors they always end up doing the
right thing and consistent with each
other and that's what Einstein believed
was going on he thought quantum
mechanics can't be the whole story there
have to be these things called hidden
variables that somehow the particles are
carrying this extra information with
them so that then you don't have any
faster than light problems because they
start you know they started close
together so they could exchange
information and then that information is
only revealed later on when you make the
measurement so let's go through that and
this this is where Belle comes in and
says Okay so let's look look at what the
consequences would be if that was what
was going on if there's one of these
things called a local hidden variable
that the particles are carrying the
information with them
what are the possibilities you know does
that is that actually consistent with
what we see these are the things that
the particles could have decided so for
example the particle that's heading
towards detector a on the left there
could have decided okay so I'm going to
be ready for my switch is in position
one red if my switch is in position two
and green if my switch is in position
three and that kind of dictates what the
other particle has to do because it
always if the switches are in the same
position it always has to be the
opposite so if it's red for position one
this one has to be green for position
one and so on they could decide any of
these things right they could decide if
they could do different things on
different occasions they could just
randomly pick from this list but this is
the menu they have to choose from and
they have to pick one of these rows and
as long as they pick from one of these
rows then if the switches are in the
same position everything comes out right
because if one's red the other's always
green just because of the way that the
symmetry of this thing or the
anti-symmetry of this thing is set up it
works fine if the switches are in the
same position but now what if the
switches are in different positions so
one's in position one and others in
position two for example so then we can
kind of go through the mass of saying
okay what fraction of the times are the
lights going to be different so let's
pick our of the same row here of red red
green if this one's in position one and
this one's in position two then they're
different colors so I'll put a tick in
there okay if this one's in position one
and this one's in position three you
know they're both red so they're the
same color so we'll put an X so what
about two if it's a position two and
position one then the different colors
two and three is another possibility you
know that's the same color what else
we've got three in one that's the same
color three and two that's the same
color so it turns out that in two of the
six cases you'll end up with different
colors
okay and it's almost all of these
combinations actually it turns out you
end up with two or six that you'll end
up with different colors just because
you're kind of picking two things out of
three most of these rows are the same
the only two that are different is if
the first particle is decided I'm
definitely going to be red which means
the other particle definitely has to be
green and then they'll just always be
different whatever the switch positions
are but if you look at this it means
that suppose for example you randomly
selected maybe the physic the laws of
physics say okay before they set off the
particles randomly choose one of these
possibilities
and would you have a possibility they
choose as I say if the switches are in
the same position everything's fine but
if the switches are in different
position what fraction of the time are
they going to come out to be different
colors and the answer is it's going to
be a little bit more than a third
because in almost all of the cases it's
a third but actually in a couple of
cases it's six out of six so there'll be
a tiny bit more than a third okay so
let's try and get it down a little bit
less than a third maybe it never the
laws of physics are such that it never
decides I'm definitely going to be red
or definitely going to be green so you
cross out these two then it's exactly a
third because all of these things are a
third so whatever thing you pick it's
going to be a third it turns out
whatever combination you pick because
all these numbers are a third or bigger
whatever the laws of physics are it'll
either be a third or more of the time
that the colors come out that's
different but remember what the actual
experiment was the actual experiment
says quantum mechanics predicts that a
quarter of the time
the colors should come up different
when the switches are in different
positions and so there's a contradiction
here right there's a paradox something
has to be wrong because
if there is a hidden variable then it's
either a third or more of the time the
switches the colors are different and
this is that's why we have an inequality
here this is this bill's inequality
thing that is a third or bigger so it's
more than a third of the time the colors
are not different whereas the quantum
mechanical prediction is it's a quarter
of the time
and so one of these has to be wrong
and it turns out if you just go and do
the experiment then it comes out a
quarter at the time that the colors are
different if the switches are in
different positions
so the quantum mechanical prediction is
right the hidden variable prediction so
the quantum mechanics with just
probabilities and nothing else is right
the idea that actually there's some more
physics going on here and the things
we've actually set before things set off
gives the wrong answer it just feels
like whatever they're doing these
entangled things yeah they're just doing
what they're doing and we're setting up
all this Shrubbery around it and getting
ourselves in a tears where like you know
your mic and if and if and if you're
just walking along your mic no matter
what and if I start doing all these
different experiments like how much
hydrogens is in his body or what's he
thinking or what's his favorite color
and all that none of that really matters
you're just you're still you and it
isn't just the same with these particles
like you can set up all these devices
and try and look at this and that and
make lights go off and that but this
they're still just going to do what
they're going to do but that's because
I'm not a quantum mechanical particle
right and it really is so this is really
to get into this question of quantum
mechanics is full of probabilities
and the question is are these
probabilities reflecting the fact that
actually there's some subtler Physics
going on that we just don't understand
and all we can say is well 50 of the
time it's going to be that and 50 of the
time it's going to be that and if we
were smarter we could actually predict
beforehand it's definitely going to be
that for this one and it's definitely
going to be that for this one or is it
kind of fundamentally unpredictable
which is what we're kind of told is the
case and that's that's what bell showed
right Einstein said Einstein really
didn't like this idea he also famously
said right God doesn't play dice he
didn't like this idea that things were
just dictated completely randomly and
his view was there has to be some
subtler Physics going on which means
that these things are actually definite
what Bill's inequality does is it says
okay if things are actually definite
then we end up with a result which
contradicts what we actually observe
and that's what this very contrived
experiment is doing but it's because you
know the mathematics behind it is
complicated so you have to set up quite
a contrived experiment in order to be
able to demonstrate that there is this
contradiction between a world in which
things are really are probably
probabilistic and random in nature and a
world in which they are actually
deterministic we're just not smart
enough to figure out what state they're
determined to be in so do I take from
this that in ways Beyond understanding
the two particles are communicating with
each other instantaneously and Joe's
telling Bill quick flip you have to flip
yep absolutely that that somehow the
information is getting from here to here
now people get as I say very worried
about this because it's like well we've
got information traveling faster than
light somehow instantaneously what's
going on here is affecting what's going
on here but the interesting thing is
there is nothing you can do to extract
useful information from that you can't
for example use it as a way of
communicating because things are
completely random it's like you know the
fact that this guy's come out red you
can't use that to infer or pass any
information to somebody over here
because that was completely random which
means their answer is completely random
so no information kind of external to
the particles gets passed between them
in that so you can't kind of have faster
than light communication or anything
like that but something is happening
faster than life it is it's happening
absolutely instantaneously
which doesn't make it feel like it was
predetermined but it wasn't
predetermined exactly that and that's
why you you know at this point your head
should start to hurt that actually it's
natural to say okay if the information
is passing instantly from here to here
it will be much easier if actually it
was all predetermined and you don't need
to pass information
but what Bell's inequality shows is that
actually if you did set things up ahead
of time so that everything is determined
then you get the wrong answer because no
information is being no usable
information is being passed that you or
I could use but information is being
passed not that electrons have brains
but information is being passed out the
electrons need yep
are you comfortable with it
with
the the random nature effects of the
situation here uh it's the way the
universe is and you know I guess you
know
I wouldn't actually tend to side with
Einstein on this in I would like things
not to be just kind of dictated by by
the flip of a coin I'd like there to
actually be some Physics that you could
kind of if we were smart enough we could
get to but what this experiment and this
Theory and experiment shows is that
there isn't there really isn't and as
far as we can tell you know that things
really are this random probabilistic
nature rather than being somehow
determined in some way we haven't yet
been able to figure out are things
happening in the universe because of
entanglement so there's the whole field
of quantum Computing right which is just
coming along now and people thinking
about whether we can come up with really
clever ways of making very fast
computations which depends on quantum
entanglement a lot of modern
cryptography for example also depends on
entanglement because this is an
unbreakable code right you know until
you make the measurement you don't know
whether what state things are in the
whole Bell's inequality thing shows as
soon as you make the measurement you've
kind of fundamentally changed things in
a way that you wouldn't have done if it
were a deterministic thing so it's sort
of fundamental to an awful lot of things
that are going on now so I'm guess what
I'm saying is if there's a whole bunch
of particles in the Milky Way that are
entangled with a whole bunch of
particles somewhere else in the universe
and something happens to those particles
I don't know what something
does that mean the particles here in the
Milky Way would react and it could have
an implication for us here in our
environments they would so this is
another whole area of quantum mechanics
as to where you kind of move over from
quantum mechanics to kind of a classical
universe and this is idea of decoherence
as to how long you can keep things in
these entangled States when you move
them apart from each other and do other
things to them and it these entangled
states are quite delicate right it's
quite easy to break them so it's
probably the case that we're not
actually affecting goings on in the
Andromeda galaxy at the moment because
of somebody doing a Stern Gerlach
experiment somewhere in the UK if some
alien species came up with a way of
obliterating matter and they and they
obliterated their matter the entangled
matter over this side of the universe
could be obliterated as well I hope not
sorry I didn't mean to put that out here
behind and so you'd have all these
problems that you know sometimes your
Earth would be over here and the
satellite will be over here and they
wouldn't be able to communicate with
each other so what you want to do
somehow is find an orbit which puts your
satellite a decent distance away from
the earth but also kind of keep station
with the Earth as the two orbit around
the Sun so a geostationary satellite is
where you've got something which stays
above the same point on the Earth